como regalo de cumpleaños soy le dio a
su sobrina una alcancía bancaria
electrónica la cual muestra la cantidad
total de dinero en la alcancía así como
la cantidad total de monedas después de
depositar cierta cantidad de monedas de
cinco centavos y de 25 centavos la
alcancía mostró lo siguiente el dinero
es 2 pesos el número de monedas son 16
cuántas monedas de 5 centavos y cuántas
de 25 centavos puso psoe en la alcancía
y bueno lo primero que vamos a hacer es
definir variables así que voy a decir
sea n igual al número de monedas de 5
centavos y ceaccu igual al número de
monedas de veinticinco centavos perfecto
ahora lo primero que sé es que la
cantidad de monedas que voy a tener son
la cantidad de maneras que tengo de
cinco centavos más la cantidad de
monedas que tengo de 25 centavos es
decir n más q en más q es la cantidad de
monedas que tengo en mi alcancía que por
cierto me dice mi alcancía que son 16 el
número de monedas que tengo son 16 y por
lo tanto en moscú es igual a 16
aquí ya tenemos la primera ecuación pero
para sacar la segunda ecuación en lo que
nos tenemos que fijar es en la cantidad
de dinero que tenemos con las monedas de
5 centavos es decir 0.05 por n
ya esto sumarle la cantidad de dinero
que tenemos en las monedas de 25
centavos por lo tanto 0.25 si estamos
hablando de pesos o 25 centavos por la
cantidad de monedas que tenemos de 25
centavos es decir por home y bueno de
hecho se podemos ser un ejemplo si q
vale 4 y viene vale 0 entonces vemos 4
por punto 25 entró cuales 1 y 0 por 0.5
pues esto no me daría nada entonces que
tendríamos un peso solamente sin embargo
lo que existe es que tiene que ser igual
a 2 pesos esto tiene que ser igual a 2
pesos porque es justo lo que me está
diciendo mi alcancía electrónica que la
cantidad de monedas que yo tengo de 5
centavos multiplicado por lo que valen
por 5 centavos más la cantidad de
monedas que yo tengo de 25 centavos
multiplicado por lo que valen las
monedas es decir 25 centavos esto tiene
que ser igual a 2 pesos y aquí ya
tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas y con dos ecuaciones por lo
tanto vamos a intentar resolver esto
por el método de sustitución así que
aquí en la primera ecuación voy a
despejar aquí y q es igual a 16 - n de
aquí estoy pasando para que solamente
restando n de ambos lados de la ecuación
y como yo sé que q vale igual a 16 - n
entonces lo que voy a hacer es sustituir
el valor de q
aquí adentro en lugar de esta cumbia
ponerlo que vale la q en mi primera
ecuación y recuerda que esto es cierto
porque si tienen que cumplir ambas
ecuaciones simultáneamente y entonces me
queda 0.05 por n más 0.25 por atún pero
recuerda vamos a sustituir aquí entonces
en lugar de q voy a poner 16 - n 0.25
por q pero cuba de 16 - n eso es lo que
nos dice la primera actuación y esto
tiene que ser igual a 2 pesos ok ahora
date cuenta que ya tengo una ecuación
con solamente una incógnita y ahora voy
a distribuir el 0.25 y dice 0.25 por 16
y 0.25 por menos en el 0.25 por 16 es lo
mismo que punto 5 por 8 que es lo mismo
que 4 por 1 es 4
y después 0.25 por menos n es lo mismo
que menos 0.25 n y esto tiene que ser
igual a 2 pesos ahora lo que voy a hacer
es restarle ambos lados de la ecuación 4
de tal manera que yo pueda sumar estos
los que tienen que ver con el 0.05 en
menos 0.25 n pues esto es lo mismo que a
ver aquí tengo 5 centavos y aquí tengo
menos 25 centavos pues esto me quedaría
menos 20 centavos entonces de estos dos
de una vez si lo reduzco me queda menos
0.2 en menos 0.20 enee menos 0.2 menos
ser punto 20 nm y bueno vamos a seguir
ya que redujimos todo lo que tenía que
ver con él y no olvidemos a este 4
entonces más 4 esto tiene que ser igual
a 2 pesos a 2.00 ahora si yo restó 4 de
ambos lados de la ecuación voy a empezar
a despejar a n entonces menos 4 menos
cuatro aquí y entonces que me queda de
lado izquierdo estos dos se van y
solamente me queda menos 0.20 n menos
0.20 n esto es lo mismo que dos menos
cuatro lo cual es
-2 muy bien y ahora para sacar el valor
de n lo que voy a hacer es dividir a
ambos lados de la ecuación entre menos
0.2 entre menos 0.2 de este lado o menos
0.20 pero los dos son lo mismo y en el
otro lado también tengo que dividir
entre menos 0.2 recuerda que los ceros a
la derecha después del punto decimal no
cuentan y por lo tanto me quedan menos 2
entre menos 0.2 y ahora si en es igual a
menos 2 entre menos 0.2 aquí menos entre
menos me da más y 2 entre 2001 y después
recorre el punto decimal y me queda 10 n
es igual a 10 y ya puedes sacar a cu de
una manera muy rápida aquí dice q es
igual a 16 - nm y por lo tanto q es
igual a 16 menos 10 lo cual es 6 en el
balde 10 q vale 6 es decir que la
cantidad de monedas que tenemos de 5
centavos son 10 y la cantidad de monedas
que tenemos de 25 centavos tienen que
ser 6
perfecto ya llegamos a la solución y
vamos a ver si realmente se cumplen las
dos actuaciones claramente estas dos
suman 16 10 + 6 me da 16 esto es muy
fácil ahora si yo quiero sacar la
cantidad de dinero que tenemos pues
tendré que multiplicar este por 5
centavos lo cual me daría pues 50
centavos o 0.50 pesos 0.50 pesos y 6 por
punto 25 es lo mismo que 1.50 pesos o
dicho de otra manera un peso con 50
centavos y si ahora sumamos las 2
claramente esto me da 2 pesos y por lo
tanto estamos bien